i cannot express it she says
feelings of anger feelings of hatred
feelings of deep contempt
for the russian soldiers who brought
death to her hometown
a former kindergarten teacher nina
yarmokova lost her lifelong home in the
invasion
sheltering in a children's summer school
in her pin
she now listens for any news of the war
russians with their boots trampled on
all our happiness people's lives
people's hope everything they trampled
everything in one minute
a passport and some medicine
precious few necessities all she was
able to take
her house now a crime scene all that she
had in this world bombed to rubble
in the winter her room was the warmest
that's why she chose it
a lifetime of memories a lifetime of
belongings she doesn't want any of it
back
send it to the russians she says so it
may weigh on their conscience
our people are dead crushed with tanks
how can we ever forgive them for it
never no one not for a hundred years
what was left standing in this city is
being fixed
one man said all he wants is to make
repairs so life can return to normal
but what was broken in a matter of
months
in some cases mere hours
will take years to rebuild
it's difficult to find a street in her
pin that hasn't been hit by gunfire or
tank shells or mortar rounds and so many
absolutely devastated buildings are now
a grim reminder that the russians were
here
not even houses of worship were spared
and even the most civilian of spaces
became targets in this war
my heart is drenched in blood and tears
that is all i have in my soul
it was artillery maybe windows were hit
and roads were hit the roof of the
kindergarten was burned my son's class
was in that building the kindergarten
doesn't exist now why should i be happy
why did this happen
it's sad a lot of people who i know were
killed
even now as the war moves away from
towns around kiev as life begins to
return to a new kind of normal
ukrainians piecing their lives back
together say they never thought russia
would actually invade they still can't
believe it happened and they still don't
understand why zain basravi al jazeera
airplane